hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game again from the isle of
man chess tournament it's a round at
Suwannee versus the Sun and Sioux Grove
and I know what you're thinking wasn't
sugar of Vincent's opponent from
yesterday's video well he was but
obviously he plays some very interesting
games so here we also have a nice game
from him in against a different opponent
and again he helped create yet another
Grandmaster but you know if everyone if
anyone did all the work is definitely
young around axel von he's 13 years old
at the moment so without further ado
let's check it out so the mining opens
up with the white pieces and he plays
efore sorry about that
we have c5 by sugar of the Sicilian
defense Knight to f3 d6 and Bishop to b5
with check we've got so the the canals
whole ski attack with Bishop the B's
Bishop to d7 Bishop captures Knight
captures on b7 and now casts let me just
fix this and Knight G to f6 with Queen
to e2 all these moves have been played
before
rook the c8 and now d3 we have Easton's
by black and now there is a game where
c4 was played and also again where
Knight to g5 was played making room for
the f4 pawn but here b3 is any move in
the position and it is already as a move
eight that we have a completely new game
so Bishop to e7 developing preparing to
Castle kingside silvana puts a bishop on
this long diagonal so Bishop to b2 with
castles and now Knight B to d2
we have Knight the b8 the knight no
longer serves the purpose here it will
be much better suited on the c6 square
so c4 grabbing more control over the d5
square with E 5 by black black does the
same now has a full control of the d4
square and now white will maybe have a
nice outpost for his knight on d5
whereas black will have a nice outpost
for his knight on d4 if the position
allows it with nice the e1 Rema nuvaring
night now to the sea to the e3 and from
e3 you can either go to d5 or to f5
depending on how black plays Knight the
c6 black does the same you want to have
control over the the d4 square and now
III further preparing f4 we have nice
the eh now black makes room for the f5
point if needed ending out nice to see
to white continues Rima nuvaring with
the night and here Bishop to f6 a more
solid move then for example f5 if you
play like in a blaze game or something
you might even play something like f5
but after it captures and rook
characters you play f4 and now the rook
might be in a bit of an awkward position
after the night comes to III and then
you can either go to d5 or or even
continue to pushing the pawn to f5 so
it's it's hard to say whether you want
to do this but black doesn't so he
continues with Bishop to f6 and nice to
e3 white continues Rema nuvaring with
the night we have g6 again making a room
for Bishop to g7 maybe then fi will be a
better choice and not finally f4 with
eek actress on f4 now opening up this
long diagonal so Bishop captures on f6
Knight captures on f6
and now G captures an f4 white ruins his
King side pawn structure but you know in
in return he gets a very nice pawn
center so he controls a lot of space
here with Knights 2d for getting to this
beautiful outpost for the night while
attacking White Queen and now Queen to
g2 and here black has to decide what to
do if black black should go for
something like Knights to h5 and now
definitely prepare to either push f5 but
White will most likely push that 5 here
and then King h8 saying okay if you want
to open up the position I'm gonna play
rook to g8 and then I'm the one that's
gonna be using the G file for attack but
here black went for Queen to a5 and it
seems like an odd move because all the
action is happening on the King side but
basically here black is saying that the
action happening on the King set is
really not important that the Queen will
be very useful on the Queen side either
by pressuring the night here so the
Queen cannot move or you can infiltrate
with Queen to c3 then maybe the d3 poem
could become a liability all in all
Salani says that's that's a poor move
he pushes 'if I've and okay the captures
with F captures on e5 attacking the
knight and not night the DISA
saying okay how are you gonna defend
your night you are maybe overreaching
here but sadhana says I'm not interested
in the point I'm interested in the
attack on the kingside so Knights the d5
offering the e5 pawn with Knight
captures on e5 and now Knight to f6 with
check with King to g7 and now Queen to
g5 with some very very nice ideas of
course if you can if you can get
something like Queen to h4 fall back
winte h7 in would be very nice but also
black has to be very careful for some
ideas like nice to h5 track getting the
Queen over to f6 and ideas like that
so first rook CT 8 sorry rook CT 8 just
trying to offer the rook but you don't
really have the option of doing it if
you go for Knight captures and yes this
does come with check but black will be
very satisfied with this for example if
rook captures any a Queen f6 check you
are gonna just move the King King to g8
and now you don't have you don't have a
good good attack anymore the knight is
very solid here the f7 point is
protected and once the Queen returns
black will be the one attacking as the
Knights are very scary here you're never
removing this knife from b2 as the
knight immediately comes to f3 and with
the White King wide open it will be in
fact black with attacking here so here
after rook c8 we have king - h1 an
excellent attacking move because like we
said you cannot move this night because
you have to keep an eye on the f3 square
for example if you try something like
this then Knight e to f3 or Knight d2 f3
it doesn't really matter wins the Queen
once the once you give up the rook then
the Queen is just captured as it's a
very nice fork so rook c8 with king - h1
now preparing to bring the knight back
into the game and he looked east 6
bringing another defender to the f6
square with nice detail for and now
finally Black has to admit that bringing
the Queen over to a5 was a bit too
ambitious so he brings it back Queen to
d8 and here here Savannah has a draw and
it's very interested interesting
Hugh Grove is almost 200 rating points
higher rated than Silvani and you know
you could go for 4/9 to h5 here with
Czech king moves king h8 night back here
threatening to win also King g7 and now
you could just repeat and you could
claim a draw here with threefold
repetition but Salman is not interested
in a draw he goes a night
the g3 point being that the knight
cannot be captured if rook captures
you're just gonna play Knight to h5
check and the ones the King moves now
you're gonna play Queen captures on e5
and black is just busted here once the
knight is captured you're gonna go rook
captures on f6 and now you're
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries here there is no move here
for black so after Knight g3 we have
King to h8 getting the King out of the
way not allowing Knight h5 to come with
the check but here so the money goes for
it either way Knight G to h5 and now
what's the point of Knight G to h5 the
point is after pawn characters and Queen
captures you are threatening mate
so the defend against mate you have to
capture on f6 now there's no mate but
now you get the similar idea Queen
captures on e5 and now the rook is again
under attack and the point is you cannot
defend it with King to g7 because just
rook captures and it's game over if
Queen captures back then just work the
g1 check King has to move and now let's
say Queen captures on f6 is checkmate
so after this wonderful 90 G to h5 move
with b5 by black saying that okay you
have a nice position but there's nothing
you know concrete going on on the Kings
side and okay rook 81 white brings
another look into the game and the now
comes rook to g8
the rook cannot be captured because the
Queen and g5 is hanging and now the
threat is G captures on h5 as this would
open up the rook roofs attack towards
the Queen and then after threatening
checkmate rook g7 would just defend
against mate but it doesn't work so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the best idea here for for white
well I give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who found rook captures an
e5 it is a winning move but there is a
quicker version and and that is Queen
Queen to h6 this is what the domani
played and congratulations to everyone
who
that as you are now threatening mate so
you have to react sugar of plate Queen
to a8 and of course sugar of salt Queen
to h6 in his calculations but here I
believe it's here that he missed a thud
Wow nice move I'm sure I'm sure he
thought about Knight d5 Knight d4 any
move that blocks check which removes one
of the attackers so the checkmate will
no longer be threatened but the move
that
Salani played is a rook to d4 and now
the main threat is still there how did
how do you defend against it so sugared
or played rook captures on f6 he removed
one of the attackers threatening mate
Knight captures on f6 and now rook the
g7 defending it but here you have a very
nice move she sort of Annie just plays
King to g1 and now that the rock is
unpinned there is no good move for black
next move you're gonna capture the night
and there is nothing black can do about
it there is no way to defend the night
and you cannot move the knight if you
move the knight then just rook to e8
Czech wins the Queen if you try to
defend it like this
two knights defending each other never
works out just captures and you remove
one of the defenders so that's not going
to work instead of this well knight
Knight captures on d3 just rotate Czech
wins the Queen and if he tries some
checks for example rook ETF three check
then just rook captures Knight captures
and now you bring the King be over to f2
and you will lose the other night as
well if you if you try and save it again
rook to e8 will win the Queen so there's
nothing you can do to continue this game
so after King to g1 sugar of resigned
and an excellent victory for around
oxide money from round one of the isle
of man chess tournament and I would just
like to show all of the players he
played against because it's very
important just to illustrate how much he
deserved his Grandmaster title so here
it is these are the opponents so round
one silence you get of the opponent
we've just seen the game on he won
against him then look at the monsters he
faced next round Sevilla Carrick in a
draw against him then a draw against soo
- Shekhar Ganguly then a draw against
even charge then a draw against Parvati
Liana then
draw against Peter like oh you know all
of these are big big monsters and every
opponent is well almost 200 rating
points high rated and Silvanus some of
them are more than 200 rating points
high ratings and money then a draw
against the Gabrielle so easy and then a
loss against Marcos Ruger but he
immediately bounces back with a win
against 2651 grandmaster alexander
multilevel then he loses the possum I
mean really nice game but I mean it was
just over over prepared for Savannah a
really nice victory for him and then in
the final round a draw against mark
simcha guys so a 13 year old
international made master faces 11
grandmasters so all of these guys are
grandmasters and all of them are like I
said some of them are more than 200
rating points higher rated and all of
them are you know around there and he
scored five and a half out of eleven so
50% against the you know feel like this
you definitely deserve a grand master
title there is no no doubt about that
so congratulations to young Sal Vani and
here I would just like to mention that
Vishwanath an island also joined in the
congratulations on Twitter
there you have it he says congrats the
round oxide money he started he started
a new chess board of GM's saying that he
is India's 65th the Grandmaster so 64
GM's or one chess board and now he
starts the other chess board he says
finally I once played him in a Simon and
mentioned that he had a great talent a
few years later at I am chess he has me
on the ropes and I I thought this kid is
just something else so this is what
Anand mentions as Anand faced him in the
year before in 2018 Anand fists of money
in an isle of man chess masters
tournament and like he said he he had
him on the roast but India and Ireland
was able to defend and to win that game
but you know that's that's Anand yeah
really really an impressive achievement
really an impressive game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
marcin's Barada Peters Wiggly era and
Mario and samosa for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it I would also like to
mention that
the the video and photo team behind the
Greinke chest classic that we've enjoyed
a lot of videos and photos from them I
have created a short documentary on
Vincent Kaymer also one of the newest
grandmasters in the world a 14-year old
and they said that they will send me the
link to this video after it's done I
thought it would be done while I'm done
recording my video so I can invite you
to check it out but they still haven't
if I receive the link it will be in the
description of this video the first link
you will see so if it's not I still
haven't received it I will then invite
you in my next video but if there's a
link in the description below you can
click on it and watch the new
documentary on Vincent climber so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day